olivier le cour grandmaison historiens
politologues bon soit olivier le cour
grandmaison merci d'être avec nous une
journée plus que symbolique avec les 20
ans de la loi taubira mais uniquement
symbolique ou avec davantage de portée
selon vous à mon avis essentiellement
symbolique jeu constaté christiane
taubira l'a dit avant moi d'autres
également qu'elle est belle elle a
conquis il ya cinq jours il a prononcé
un discours important et pour rendre
hommage à napoléon et qui a par la suite
également de participer à des cérémonies
n'a aujourd'hui on se dit mais elle pas
prononcer une parole
il est vrai que le constat la
comparaison est pour le moins singulière
je rappelle que le porte parole du
gouvernement et gabriela talent avait
dit que le président de la république et
le gouvernement vous souhaitez regarder
l'histoire en face je crains que sur ce
chapitre
emmanuel macron de soufre d'un strabisme
divergent arcis l'orienter vers la
droite emmanuel macron qui a pourtant
estimé injustement lors de son hommage
au bicentenaire de la mort de napoléon
que la décision de l'empereur de
rétablir l'esclavagé avait été une
trahison de l'esprit des lumières dont
kylie c'est tout même positionné une
trahison
assurément et pardon mais il a découvert
que des parfums 40
d'une part parce que contrairement à ce
que certains disent et affirmé pour
justifier cela
la critique de l' esclavage est
antérieure à la à son rétablissement
après que la convention abolisse
cavaliers saison 94 et que cette
abolition en droit ne fait que
sanctionner ceux qui a été arraché par
les esclaves de même dès le mois d'août
1793 ce qu'elle veut dire par là c'est
que les critiques adressées à
l'institution de des stars âge adressé
aux comme moi ont été faites d'une part
par des conventionnels par les
révolutionnaires mais évidemment aussi
par les esclaves de même
qui lassé des atermoiements de la
révolution et de la convention parachève
à liberté l'égalité en menant un combat
difficile à saint domingue
clairement aujourd'hui qu'elles
devraient être selon vous les mots
prononcés par emmanuel macron quelle
doit être l'attitude du chef de l'état
je suis très surpris que mails mâcon ne
reprennent pas à la fois l'esprit et la
lettre de la loi taubira et du 10 mai et
rappelle qu effectivement l'esclavagé
son exploitation sont l'existence le
code noir ont été constitutive d'un
crime contre l'humanité est par ailleurs
et là aussi c'était prévu dans la loi
taubira du 10 mai s'est targué article a
disparu au cours de la navette
parlementaire
il était prévu à l'origine des
réparations la question jury se poser à
ce groupe d'autant plus vous l'avez
signalé çà a été signalé dans le sujet
présenté aux états unis la chose est
désormais à l'agenda politique et non
pas seulement à la zone art politique il
ya une petite ville pas très loin à eux
de chicago qui a décidé et d'accorder
pour les dix ans à venir environ des
sommes très considérable en dollars aux
descendants d'esclaves c'est-à-dire aux
infos étasunien dit c'est qu'il ya
encore quelle plus salée et sinon
quelques mois était considérée comme une
revendication radical illusoire et
désormais effectivement à l'agenda
politique aux états unis et est déjà
entrée en vigueur dans certains cas il
me semble que sur ce chapitre
encore une fois la france est très en
retard puisque et mâcon l'anil prononcer
le mot du crime contre l'humanité et
évidemment eu moins encore celui de
réparation il faut aller donc plus loin
que là que la recontre pente ans selon
vous il faut des actes concrets de
réparation juste une précision personne
parmi eux celles et ceux qui demandent
la reconnaissance qui établit dans la
loi du 10 mai ne parle de repentance et
il s'agit bien plutôt d'une
reconnaissance d'une reconnaissance
politique une reconnaissance symbolique
et je crois qu'effectivement il faut
aller plus loin en termes de du côté des
repas
a sion parce que contrairement à ce que
disent aussi un certain nombre de
personnes
l'esclavagé n'est pas un passé passé ou
plus exactement ce sont les effets de l'
esclavage qui n'appartiennent pas au
passé et qui continue d'affecter les
populations afro descendantes qui vivent
principalement aux antilles et en guyane
à la réunion mais sans doute aussi en
métropole alors lors de cette journée de
mémoire de l'esclavagé
marine le pen a pris la parole elle a
dénoncé les formes d' esclavage moderne
comme le trafic d'êtres humains en
méditerranée je suis ton courage elles
sont couvert d'humanisme des voiliers
des ong des domineront quelle est votre
réaction c'est un terme adéquat selon
vous alors nous savons et parce que
c'est d'augmenter de façon très précise
à un certain nombre d'objets ou de suaux
d'exception amitiés internationales et
du roi coach qu'effectivement en libye
où ce qu'il reste de la vie plus active
en est qu'il est plus sain et âpre pour
en parler il y avait effectivement et
c'est maintenant très bien documenté y
compris d'ailleurs par le haut
commissariat aux réfugiés et des formes
d'esclavagé star ac de vente d'hommes de
femmes et de migrants marine le pen ne
serait bien inspirée d'une part de
condamner tous les esclavages est
également celui dont la france et s'est
rendu coupable de 785 1794
je fais simplement ajouté le une chose
on entend beaucoup dire que l'esclavagé
a été aboli définitivement par la grâce
des décrets et 27 en 1848
ce n'est pas vrai sous la troisième
république et notamment en afrique
subsaharienne la troisième république
qui a construit virulent le plus grand
empire colonial de france se trouve
confronté un nouvel esclavage qu'elle
esclavage domestique ou de cases et cet
esclavage n'a pas été abolie par les
autorités coloniales comme par les
autorités métropolitaine
clairement ça veut dire aujourd'hui
qu'en 2021 il existe de nombreuses
formes d'esclavagé moderne
selon vous il existe des nombreuses
parts mais déclaré assez moderne il en
existe en afrique subsaharienne il en
existe encore dans un état en
particulier au dos au moins elle pour
serrer les skis de cette afrique
subsaharienne la morita ligne d'une part
et le signe que le mali dans les deux
cas ça concerne des lignes sont elles
des milliers d'hommes de femmes et de
mineur et qui sont encore et escales et
faut-il le rappeler dans certains cas s
il arrive en france et qu'ils arrivent à
faire la démonstration qu'ils ont été
esclaves dans leur pays d'origine ils
peuvent se voir accorder pour cette
raison le statut de réfugié par ailleurs
ancien que dans d'autres continents et
en asie du sud-est et en inde il ya
encore des millions d'esclaves le pour
dettes et que par ailleurs dans un
certain nombre de pays du golfe et
ailleurs il ya des conditions de travail
qui sont imposés avec des restrictions
très importantes des droits et libertés
fondamentaux absence de véritable
salaire
l'ensemble de ces éléments là étant
effectivement dans certains cas le
constitutive de l'esclavagé contemporain
merci beaucoup olivier le cour
grandmaison d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france